and so today my talk is going to be
about responsive web and a few months
ago my company decided to undergo a
visual brand redesign where they get to
unify the design language of the site
but at the same time they wanted to make
the site responsive so during the
responsive web project I noticed that we
did a lot of mistakes that we could have
avoided if we had known of the common
problems in responsive web development
earlier so this is what my talk is going
to be about today it's going to be about
the responsive web mistakes that we did
how we solve it and what you can do to
avoid it so a little bit about me I'm a
Shawn Raney
I go by Ren Aisha on the Internet
I work as a front-end engineer at Vicky
Vicky is a global TV site powered by
France where fans gets from communities
to supply those two shows on the site
responsive web development workflow is
very different from a non responsive one
and I learned this the hard way
so this because in responsive web divide
an on responsive website you have a site
that is supposed to work on several
browsers and it should only work on
desktop but on responsive site you have
several different screen sizes and
different devices that you need to take
into account off and during my time
working on the project I noticed that
there are three common problems that
keep on recurring and this problem
always centers on how designers and
developers work together how to ensure
that you're writing maintainable code
and coming up with testing and debugging
strategy more often than not I think
responsive web development will force
you to change your design development
and testing workflow and I find that
changing this workflow is especially
challenging especially when you're
working on revamping a non responsive
site to a responsive one because chances
are you and your team members are
already used to
working on the non responsive web
development workflow which brings me to
my very first blooper of the day
initially during our responsive web
project we had a lack of collaboration
between designers and developers
there's a lot of back-and-forth style of
communication between us and initially
this communication works fine for us
during our pre responsive era but during
the project itself it becomes a major
problem and as you know old habits die
hard
without actually noticing it we adopt
the same communication style in a
responsive web project and it turns out
to be a problem for us so what do I
meant by a back and forth style
communication so you have a designer and
designer will pass a high fidelity
design markup to developer and during
the development stage this is when the
developers start to find problems with
the design and when problems are found
design gets passed back to the designer
this is when the designers start to get
stressed out and start thinking about
all of the possible solutions that they
can use in order to solve the problem
and once the solution is found the
design mock-up gets updated and get
passed back to developer but it's not
the end of the story because problems
will keep on being found and the cycle
will just keep on repeating itself so I
have three reasons why this type of
communication actually failed during
responsive web development and the first
thing is limitation see designers are
creative beings I wish I can be half as
creative as them but most of the time I
only like to pretend to be a designer on
a daily basis and so whenever I look at
my designers working it impresses me
because there's no limitation to their
creativity but there's always going to
be limitation when you start developing
their ideas for example a designer may
come to you with fancy anime
and there's always going to be
limitations on how this animation would
render on smaller screen dividers - and
and also in older browsers designers
will come to you with big images to be
implemented on the site but there's
always going to be limitations on how
this images would affect the performance
of your site and also the art direction
on your smaller screen devices of your
site and designers may also come with
beautiful and intricate layouts but
there's always going to be limitation in
terms of the difference in expectation
on how this layouts supposed to render
on smaller screen to larger screen
devices for example my designer come up
to me one day and show me this mock-up
this is the blueprint of the mock-up and
how it should render on large screen
device as you can see the episodes clips
and trailers should appear as a sidebar
so at a glance I understand that on
smaller screen device the sidebar should
appear right under the main content area
and in this case the episodes clips and
trailers should appear under collections
but my designer has a totally different
expectation so he expects the episodes
to appear right below the About section
while the clips and trailers should
appear right below collections so this
is an example of the difference of
expectations that you may encounter when
you're working on such a project and
when you're working closely with the
designer this is the kind of
expectations that you should communicate
verbally to each other and that you
should not rely on markups alone to pass
the message effectively which brings me
to my second reason on why such a
communication style fail the markups
itself mock-ups don't really tell you
much about what's the performance of
your site's going to be like it doesn't
tell you much about the development
complexity that you may run into when
you start developing the site and most
importantly it doesn't really tell you
about the interaction types it's going
to be on your site so there's this
amazing quote by Tom Maslin Tom
is actually a developer working on
responsive web development at BBC I got
this quote from a book called real life
responsive web design by Smashing
Magazine I was out earlier this year I
suggest everyone who's working on
responsive website to read the book I
wish I stumbled upon it earlier
so basically Tom's quote summarizes that
you can't really assume that small
screen devices interaction is going to
be done by touch while a large screen
one will be done by mouse and you would
understand where Tom is coming from if
you actually take an iPad visit a site
on iPad and switch it to landscape mode
if most of it I will take the desktop
set of design and depending on your
design where your interaction type works
seamlessly on desktop it will start to
fail on the iPad landscape mode so this
is the kind of design problems that you
may encounter this is the kind of
limitations that you may encounter and
the third reason is shortcomings design
shortcomings will be discovered really
late and in our case it's always
discovered during the development stage
and this is when you will start thinking
about employing different kinds of hacks
shortcuts and libraries and I don't
think she's just gonna be happy for your
code climate if you make it a habit and
also if there's any last-minute picture
that you forgot to include it will
actually you won't be able to squeeze it
and for example @viki we have very
passionate users we have users working
as volunteers to actually provide
subtitles on the site on a daily basis
and we actually value the opinions of
these users because we want to make your
job easier for them but at the same time
we want the site to be fun for them to
use so when we roll out the responsive
web they were complaining about a
feature that we missed out which is the
cinematic mode feature so just to walk
you through our previous workflow we
have
a high fidelity design markup that we
test and validate once we go to the
development stage this is where we lost
a lot of time due to the back-and-forth
style of communicating with each other
once we start to roll it up for better
testing and ask users but their opinions
on the side this is when they start
suggesting feature requests that we have
no time for so after applying some
finishing touch we decided to roll the
side out
but this there was a lot of backlash
from the users because we actually did
not include the cinematic mode feature
that they liked so much so initially pre
responsive era we had the cinematic mode
as a default but when we actually wrote
the responsive site we no longer have
the cinematic mode this is when we have
a lot of criticism from our users like
the site started to look very much like
a hospital it looks too white too bright
it's really hard for me to actually
watch my shows all of these kinds of
first world problems but so this but
when but we understand after
interviewing the users we actually
understand where they are coming from
because they don't actually view this
video on full view mode and the reason
is because they like to multitask and
viewing videos on full view mode there's
not allowed them to do that I know that
this problem this communication style is
just going to be more of a problem for
us in the long run so I suggested a
different way of working to my designers
one day and after a bit of banter they
finally agree with it and it's more of a
collaborative style of working so what
does a collaborative workflow looks like
right now at viki so we have a designer
who passed in a low fidelity mock-up or
sketches to the developer and this is
where the developer would start
prototyping the mock-up this is where
the developer would start assessing the
problems the potential problems that
could happen with design and from this
from these problems discovered Duvall
will start giving feedback to the
designer on what works and what doesn't
and based on this information the
designer would then start designing
based on constraints they would start
developing a high fidelity mock-up based
on the constraints set by the developer
and we find that this is a very
effective way of working together
because the developer is highly involved
in the design and ultimately your design
is decided in the browser and not true
Photoshop and the only way to access
your design more effectively is true
browsers because only browsers can tell
you what kind of interaction types works
for you and if you're only solely
designed in Photoshop most of the time
you're making a lot of assumption and
then that assumption may or may not be
true and most time you will make a lot
of mistakes through that assumption when
I first suggested this style of working
there's a lot of doubts coming from my
team members because they feel that
prototyping will take a lot of time so
if you have the same concern I would say
that there's nothing to worry about
because it's not necessary to put it up
everything
for me what I like to put it up is I
just like to get the layout work just
understanding how the layout would
behave on smaller screen device through
a large screen one and also I also like
to test the interaction types seeing how
it works on smaller screen devices and
well as well and the role of prototyping
is I read somewhere that the rule of
prototyping should be less than an hour
to build and you shouldn't care much
about aesthetic the rule is to just
build fast and bill ugly and also if you
have a pattern library which we have
@viki
it'll make prototyping that much faster
so just to walk you through our new
workflow we have a design mock but prior
to that we have been prototyping and we
have access the feasibility of the
design and then we start
thing it once we get to development
stage we noticed that there's a last
time last year compared to before
because we finally know if there's a
problem we know about it beforehand
we're not surprised by it anymore and we
definitely know how to solve it this
time
and once we roll it out for better
testing if there's any feature requests
that we can still squeeze in we will do
it before rolling it out so I talked a
lot about losing time and as developers
I think that one of our concern when
we're working on big project is deadline
and I think deadlines could be worrying
about deadlines could be a bad thing
because you'll get really excited just
start developing right away and that
could be a bad thing because that means
that there's a lack of planning on
development and when there's a lack of
planning on development it would
actually be dangerous because you will
notice that your technical depth will
start to increase and when your
technical Doug increases you need to
actually allocate time in the future to
start refactoring your code and when
you're working on a product centric
company like Vickie we have product
development on a quarterly basis when we
need to allocate time for refactoring
and also allocating time for product
development it can get pretty
overwhelming so I was reviewing my CSS
code one day there were two other guys
writing the CSS code with me and I
noticed that there's a lot of
inconsistency there's an inconsistent
ways of writing media queries one file
the media queries is written in nested
manner while the other one is
unnecessary time in writing CSS on one
file it is written in a mobile-first
manner and another file it's written in
our desktop first manner which is very
inconsistent and the first thing that I
wish I had done is to actually come up
with a coding style guide before
starting development just thinking about
naming conventions and how you're going
to organize your files and also think
about the many the nesting levels
sometimes
notice that some developers can get very
carried away in nesting their SAS they
could go to five to six levels and
that's not going to be very performant
for your code and also think about how
you're going to write your media please
set the kind of standards on how you
should write it in order to maintain
consistency because consistency is the
key to maintainability I want to talk a
little bit about naming conventions I
think there's a lot of paradigm out
there and it could be overwhelming to
pick which one that you're going to use
for example the top trees that I have
learned about is Bam Oro CSS and Smacks
but ultimately it doesn't really matter
which naming conventions you're going to
use but your team members do do care
about it and my advice is to actually
sit down with your team members decide
on which naming conventions that you
want to use and actually stick with it
the sticking with it is important
because don't make it up as you go along
the way because it's just going to
increase your technical depth I have
some resources that I want to share with
you because coming up with a coding
style guide initially can get pretty
overwhelming you may not know where to
start
the first one is CSS guidelines by Harry
Roberts I think there's some really
amazing recommendations here
there's also if you're writing sass this
was a style guide written by Chris
coiour I think also again amazing
recommendations but my personal favorite
is sass guidelines by Hugo guru del I
like this the most because he actually
includes further readings that you can
learn more about why he recommends
certain things in a specific manner so
another thing that you need to think
about is si you have deadlines and it's
very very tempting to just jump into
development straight away and one of
them is to actually quickly just use
frameworks but the thing about
frameworks is that sometimes it has more
than what you actually need we just
contributes more to CSS blowed it will
just bloat the CSS file
and also I found that certain frameworks
could be very opinionated and it's very
rigid to actually override their classes
and therefore it's not that
straightforward also I noticed that it
is important to pick the right framework
because an unsuitable framework can be
more harmful than no frameworks at all
this is because with unsuitable
frameworks you're going to spend a lot
of time just taking those code out and
rewriting everything at the end of the
day but this is not to say that I am
against framework 100% I think that
there are justified reasons for you to
use CSS frameworks I just think that it
is important to pick the right one
there's different school of thoughts to
this for example for some people
bootstrap may not be a good framework
but for some other people it's a good
one so I think that ultimately you
should go with a battle-tested framework
that is well known like bootstrap or
foundation and if you decide not to use
frameworks at all you can always learn
from it use it as a guideline so that's
my suggestion for you and of course when
you start working on responsive web
development you will run into different
kinds of issues like browsers and device
issues so the best way to deal with this
early is to decide on a target browsers
and device and there are several reasons
to this first one is because you want to
know what the problem is with the
devices so for example if you decided to
support Android 2.3 I heard a lot of
horror stories about it so you can know
about the problems beforehand and you
can let your designers know about it so
that they can also design within that
constraint and also it is useful so that
you can research the issues beforehand
there's an amazing github repo called
device box created by Scott jail I think
it's amazing because he actually
described some of those issues in a very
specific manner and also he actually
lists how you can reproduce this
those issues and also there's also
suggestions on workaround on how to
bypass those issues now of course when
it comes to device box I think the best
way to actually deal with it is to start
testing on device early which brings me
to my third and very last blooper of the
day we start testing late on device and
realize we relied too much on emulators
and the reason for that is we're too
used to our non responsive web
development workflow we never actually
need to test on device before so we
didn't have the habit of testing with
devices before but I think it's really
important to just start device testing
early because you want to test those
interaction is the scrolling working as
expected on mobile devices is touch
working as expected
does a drop down disappear when you
click outside of the drop down things
like that and also certain bugs and
quirks only happens on mobile and
sometimes specific device I have this
really weird bug that happened only on
Sony Xperia I can't really remember the
version but when a user actually visited
a video page and started viewing the
video in full view mode and once they
actually copped out and go back to the
normal mode the site actually zoom in
into the nav bar but we actually noticed
this kind of late because we didn't get
into the habit of testing on devices
early so I think it's important to think
about your workflow I think it is
important to include testing on devices
as frequently as possible so this how my
previous workflow look like I will build
all of the UI components in a particular
page then I'll deploy the staging and
then I start to test it but this is at
the end of the development this is where
I find a lot of tree build bugs on
mobile which I could have fixed earlier
if I knew about it earlier so I kind of
changed the workflow to be better in a
that I will just build a UI component
and I will connect my local deaf
environments in my mobile phones there's
a lot of way to do that via IP address
and this is where I find a lot of
trivial box where I can then fix it
immediately right so repeating it off
after developing all of the others UI
elements once I actually deployed the
staging and start testing it I noticed
that there are no longer too much
trivial box I can focus on the major
ones and so I know that sometimes we
have non-trivial back-end for some of
you you guys may use you guys may work
with third-party web services then
connecting to mobile may not be as easy
there's two tools that would like to
introduce you guys one his local tunnel
another one is proxy local it actually
creates a poxy of your local environment
and makes it available on the Internet
my and you can actually assess your
access your your site through local
turned out on other devices my only
complaint is that it can be really slow
now testing on testing on devices every
time can be very overwhelming especially
if you have a lot of devices so
sometimes whenever I look at how my
product managers are my QA engineers
test the site it could be very painful
to watch because they will actually test
one by one on iPhone and then they'll
test another time repeat the same thing
on Android and then test it again on
desktop it's just very repetitive
there's a a tool that I would like to
introduce you guys is called girls lab
ghost lab actually allows you to
simultaneously test on multiple devices
and you can actually just access your
site on one device and whatever actions
that you do on that particular device
will get repeated on all of these other
devices that you think through ghost lab
and it just really makes testing
manually much more enjoyable
and the thing about responsive web that
I think you need to do as well as in
terms of testing it's important to start
researching the kinds of tool that will
make testing easier and this is when we
can start thinking about visual
regression tools visual regression tools
can actually allow you to compare two
different screenshots and actually find
the difference between those two
screenshots this allows you to kind of
test your CSS a little bit better
the thing about CSS is breaking it is
very easy but testing it is very very
hard and so I come across this visually
regreted regression to a car race race
is actually developed by the amazing
folks at BBC what it does is that you
can actually take two different screen
shots for example screenshot of your
local environment and compare it to the
screenshot of your production
environment and it will spit out a
difference between those two screenshots
of it you can pinpoint the error and
what I like the most about width is that
it actually creates a gallery that lists
all of your screenshots and it
categorizes it based on the screen size
and this is an example of a section so
as you can see we have one screenshot
that I took from my local environment
and the other one is from my production
environment I will pinpoint the
percentage of difference the third
images of a point up the percentage of
difference of these two screenshots and
if the error exceeds a certain number of
percentage in our case it's 20 percent
it will spit out an error this is a cool
thing as well because you can actually
control the sensitivity of your test you
can make it less than.this sensitive or
more sensitive for example we set it up
to 20 percent any any kind of difference
that exceeds that will spit out an error
and as you can see the third screenshot
what it does that is superimposes
two of these images together and
highlights the difference in blue in
this case it's just difference in ads so
it's not a big deal
but the thing about visual regression
tool is that it's not perfect during my
short time of using it I encountered
several problems for example it doesn't
really render lazy loaded items as
effectively as I thought it's going to
be and because of that it generates a
lot of false positives where it part it
has an error when it is not an error at
all and another thing is it can be very
slow depending on how many screenshots
that you are taking so I have several
suggestions on how to handle those the
first thing is regarding lazy loaded
items and false positive there is a
setting actually this a setting about a
timeout that you can increase so that
the snapshot with the snapshot process
is delayed this will wait for all of
your lazy loaded items to be rendered
before taking this snapshot and another
thing is if you have lazy loaded images
that will only appear if you scroll down
another thing is there's a settings and
options under a setting called browser
height where you can increase it just to
make sure that it scroll all the way and
every images gets rendered as expected
in terms of slow I'm still working on it
but one of the things that I think we
should do is to just a limit testing
just test critical pages for example at
Vicky's one of the most critical pages
for us is our video page this is where
we wanted this is a page that we want to
test all the time but perhaps other
non-critical pages like say your about
page or a static landing page this is
something that perhaps you may not care
so much about perhaps it's not important
for you to test so we're not completely
done yet the responsive web project has
only been going on for about more or
less three months now and we still have
a lot of work to do it's still a work in
progress
and I think that I'm pretty sure I will
find more bloopers
the way and I think maybe this talk
should have a sequel and but that's what
I have for you and I just want to say
thank you for your attention today
thank you how many devices do you pick
for your test and like you know is there
any good criteria of like which device
we should pick we actually use data
analytics to actually test to actually
pick our devices we have a list of
device that we are choosing from but I
think the best strategy that we use is
actually we have a diverse of device
when it comes to our staff members and
we actually tell them to test it on
their devices as well that's how we
actually found the Sony Xperia bug which
is pretty random
so there's actually kind of in-house
testing but my suggestion to that is
actually go through your data analytics
to see what devices is popular amongst
your user and actually focus on that